hey guys what's up this is andrew for
transcendences.com so in this video guys
i'm here to tell you about something
amazing i'm here to tell you about salt
spot which is an nft project that is the
future this is the metaverse guys and
i'm gonna explain to you why so let's
get into it
[Music]
all right guys so soft spot is an nft
project that is a web 3 application so
for those who are not familiar with what
is web 2 and web three applications let
me just explain quickly web to
application is the past is facebook
instagram twitter everything that we are
using the most right now
and that where you can have a profile
that is defined by who you are web3
applications is the metaverse guys this
is the future because and there is such
a growing demand for for this because in
the web 3 applications your profile is
not determined by who you are but by
what you do and this is the difference
and this is why people are so uh
demanding for that so let me uh explain
to you what is south spot so basically
south spot is an nft project that is on
the solana blockchain and they are
growing very very fast they're gonna
have the mint in two days three days
guys so maybe you can still have some
whitely spots i'm gonna explain to you
how uh but first let me tell you quickly
what they do so here is the white pepper
i'm not gonna read it with you but just
a summary so that you understand quickly
south spot is a snapshot of a person's
online activity with the online solenoid
blockchain so basically everything
you're gonna do on the solana blockchain
is gonna be retrieved by this company
and is going to appear in your nft i'm
going to show you how the nft is going
to look like guys and you're going to
see this is not a usual nft project but
let's be honest most of nft projects are
useless this is
the future once again and the followers
base is very very strong and they're
very excited about what is happening so
this snapshot is created automatically
by scanning for the activity on the
solana blockchain uh so for example let
me just explain quickly i'm going to
show you how it works uh so let me show
you how it works guys so when you arrive
on their website you can hear click on
manage profile they have already uh a
first version of what you can do i
created my profile it's very easy you
just connect to selena wallet uh you
need to have some nft the application to
work and give you results so i have here
my crypto booth guys you know crypto bus
and you can basically you know write
whatever you want and the
nft that is going to be created by soul
spot is going to take into account your
nft so the it's going to put in first
your most valuable nft you can here add
something so for example
crypto bools
are very cool all right here i can
choose the color all right so you can
basically customize your nft based on
your solana blockchain activity and
based on what you want so me i like the
blue guys i'm going to take a cool blue
sky blue maybe all right that's very
cool okay then you can add you know
content lists so you can add a website
so for example i'm gonna take you know
solid spot website bam
i'm gonna add it here
okay and you can add something else so
for example crypto bowls
all right and we're gonna add our
twitter
all right
okay
and then you can add a youtube video so
i'm not gonna do it here but you can add
a lot of information about you this is
the information i have on the the
blockchain and then you just save here
right
up
okay password so you need to connect
your phantom wallet all right
okay i need to connect
um
okay
and now view profile and all right so
this is my profile but this is not how
the nft would be looking uh the nft
would be looking like that guys all
right so here uh you can go and check
the twitter i'm gonna share the links of
the twitter of the discord so basically
they're having the mint on may 3rd it's
going to be sold out guys in less than
an hour than one hour i'm sure of this
because i can see the engagement they
have on their twitter and their discord
so basically they are growing by around
1 000 followers every day since i
started to follow them so i started to
follow that follow them three days ago
they were roughly at 7 000 followers now
it's 11 500. i'm gonna refresh at the
end of the video i'm sure it's gonna be
more and they have just released how the
nft would be looking so it's going to be
something like this guys all right so
you have here once again unft that is
the most valuable you have here you have
a lot of different cool things for
example here i have my qr code so if i
scan that let's see if it's working
what's going to happen
up bam i go on soft spot
and i find my profile alright so i'm not
sure you're going to see but you can
share your profile with the qr code you
can add what is this copy to clean board
okay you can add the link here so
basically this is your digital identity
this is who you are on the solenoid
blockchain and once again this is why
this is so futuristic because you know
people are tired of with two
applications that are just
representing your body who you are in
reality here you can create customize
your own profile based on what you want
so web 3 applications basically they
have no boundaries you can become who
you want you are what you do and this is
so cool and if you manage to have a
whitelist spot for their mint once once
again which is in three days you are
gonna be amongst the very lucky nft
holders that are gonna have the
opportunity to customize
with some very cool widgets uh some you
know more uh cool things to add uh their
profile and they're gonna be the ones
that contributed to develop this project
so once again i showed you guys uh here
they are growing very very fast
if you go in their twitter so you can
see here midnight may 3rd so there are
three days left i know they have still a
little bit of whitelist spot so you can
still try to get some go to the discord
just beg for it maybe you're gonna
manage to get one
i saw they posted today something a few
hours ago they still have three
whitelist spots giveaway so they're
still giving some but you're gonna need
to be very very quick because once again
this project is uh you know bringing a
really something to the blockchain
environment and this is why their
followers are just you know crazy
excited about what is gonna happen so
what else can i tell you guys about this
project so we didn't finish to read that
they can customize the profile okay we
saw that the snapshot shows who you are
what projects you're involved in and
allows you to share your profile with
anyone easily i've shown you guys how to
do that so once again i'm very very
happy that i came across this project i
managed to secure a white list for
myself so i'm going to be in this and
guys i will i will let you know you know
how they they are doing but let's
refresh quickly their twitter all right
let's see if they grew
okay so still 11 500 but i'm sure that
by the time you're gonna see this video
if you follow them on twitter you're
gonna see guys this is a very very
uh promising project that is going
extremely fast and i'm gonna keep
updating you guys about what is
happening there thank you very much for
watching this video i hope you enjoyed
that and if you did please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore see you guys